[Music]
former co-star Kit Harington and Rose
Leslie said their fairy tale I Do's in
Scotland and it also served as one big
Westeros reunion
there were bet pipes and showers of
flower petals celebrating the union the
31 year old bride wore a $20,000 tulle
and lace gown from La Salle Bridal the
groom also 31 was decked out and a coat
and Tails for the hour-long ceremony
which took place at the nine hundred
year old castle owned by Rosa's family
you know Newton Chinese smile so which
game of thrones cast members made the
guest list there's mother of dragons
Emilia Clarke
she plays Jon Snow's current love
interest and also his aunt Peter
Dinklage was there along with kit Stevie
brother Richard Madden who was killed at
the red wedding and co-star Joe Dempsey
but the style standout sophie turner and
a head turning bright red mini dress
with over-the-knee louis vuitton boots
Sophie's plus-one was Maisie Williams
not fiance Joe Jonas who spent the day
solo at Paris Fashion Week Anna Kendrick
summed up Twitter's reaction to Sophie's
look saying quote when your friends have
a traditional wedding but your fashion
as hell and not gonna hide it
[Music]